so this is a brief outline of the talk
so a lot of my talk overlap with talks
by lenka Andrea but i will review some
of these things and then i will try to
go a bit more into the physics
conjectures for random csps and what
that has to do with proof approaches for
locating shark threshold so following
this approach that was introduced by
leslie these are are some of the people
who have contributed to our
understanding of this model okay so just
to review we're looking at the the
boolean set problem which I think by now
everyone is very familiar so usually we
represented in this way you have n
variables they they take values true
false or plus/minus subject to some
collection of constraints or clauses and
each clause is constraining some small
subset of the variables and the
computational question is to decide if
you can assign plus minus values to all
of the variables so that each constraint
is satisfied
okay so this is one of the canonical
examples of a CSP and for a lot of CSPs
including this one the best algorithms
have exponential run time on the worst
case instances and this is one of the
early motivations for trying to develop
some notion about the the average case
behavior of these models and one
direction for that would be to to
introduce some natural model of a random
CSP and then to take the system size to
get larger and larger and ask when you
when you sample from your ensemble of
random csps what's the typical behavior
that you see in these random
realizations and this this line of
research has been pursued since since
the 80s okay so so usually will
represent a case I'd problem by a
bipartite factor graph so the variables
are on one side the clauses are on the
other side and then edges are colored
blue or yellow so the the blue edges
correspond to the plus literals in the
classes and the yellow edges correspond
to the negative literals in the classes
and in each clause you need at least one
literal to evaluate to true for the
formula to be satisfied
so so this is the deterministic model
and the random ke saath model a standard
model for it is as follows so you you
fix the the value K which is the width
of the clause and you fix the the clause
density alpha and you put down n
variables and then you want to put down
n times alpha clauses but n times alpha
may not be integer so put down a post on
with mean and alpha clauses ok and then
you put random edges between the
variables and clauses to say which
variable participates in which clause so
each Clause has degree k k outgoing
edges for each outgoing edge you just
connect it independently to a random
variable so all of the edges are
independent and then you color them all
independently blue or yellow for a plus
or minus so it gives you a random biker
tide graph which we view equivalently as
a random k sath problem instance so this
gives some average case version of the
of the case at problem
okay so this this particular model for
random ke saath it was experimented on
since the since the 80s or so and on the
basis of numerical simulations it was
conjectured that there's a sharp
satisfiability threshold so so it means
that you you fix the value of K and then
you consider what happens as you
gradually add more and more classes so
you gradually increase alpha and then
for each value of alpha you can look at
what's the probability for your random
instance to be satisfiable so this is
for N equals 50 it's a simulation which
shows that the probability goes from
close to one to close to zero in a
fairly abrupt way and the conjecture is
saying that this probability it should
decrease smoothly for each finite value
of n but as you take the limit of n it
should converge to this sharp threshold
function and then for any value of alpha
smaller the probability to be satisfied
converges to 1 in the limit of n tending
to infinity and 20 above
so since the since the early 90s in
these works it was known that this is
true for K equals to where the
transition occurs around equals 1 but it
was open for K larger than two although
simulations suggested that 44 k equals 3
it would occur at around between 4.2 and
4.3 okay so one of the one of the
earlier mathematical breakthroughs on
this question was freed goods theorem
which is that there's a sharp threshold
sequence so freed goods theorem says
that there are two possible pictures
that you can have so this top picture is
what the conjecture is saying that you
have a sharp transition and the location
of alpha doesn't depend on n freed goods
theorem says that you do have a sharp
transition but it leaves open the
possibility that the place where the
transition occurs is a function of N and
it may not converge so if it doesn't
converge it means that you have this
non-trivial interval of alpha where the
probability to be satisfiable also
doesn't converge it doesn't have a limit
so also what was rigorously known our
quantitative upper and lower bounds on
where this interval can take place so
the the upper bound is the best upper
bound wasn't this work of curious at all
and in recent work Oregon and panagiota
they got a lower bound which is off from
the upper bound by by some small gap so
it's a finite gap for every every K but
it tends to 0 in the limit of large K
and there was actually a series of
series of works that address the the
lower bound so I won't go into this in
much detail but I
that up to today the the best
algorithmic lower bounds are are very
far below the boundary of where we know
the solutions to exist so this value
it's around if you remember from andreas
targets around 2 to the K times log of 2
and these are off by a factor of about k
over log k so but by a huge factor from
the threshold so this talk however i
will focus on on getting a sharp
threshold so this is a it was predicted
by physicist the the exact location of
this transition so you can there's a
paper by merchants and measured and
sakina so they have an exact formula for
all k larger than 2 and in joint work
with Alan and jam ding we showed that
this formula is true for sufficiently
large K but it remains open for small K
and I will focus in this talk on the
physics prediction but so before doing
that so let's let's review this
calculation which was also in in andreas
top so throughout i'm going to call this
for the the space of satisfying
assignments of the formula so given the
formula you have some collection of
satisfying assignments it's some subset
of the binary n dimensional cube and let
said count the number of those so i will
just drop the g if if it refers to the
random case that formula so that is a
random variable which is between 0 and 2
to the N and if we ask about
satisfiability then we just want to know
it is that going to be positive or is it
0
okay so one more thing we put Poisson
and alpha classes it doesn't really
matter because it's so well concentrated
around n times office so let's just
assume from now that N equals M equals n
times alpha okay so then what's the
expected number of solutions so this is
the number of all possible assignments
that you can give to the variables it's
2 to the N and each of those it will be
satisfiable with the same probability
because you put down clauses
independently all of these are
independent so the chance to violate a
single clause the chance to violate it
is just one out of two to decay because
to violate it you need all k literals to
evaluate to false so this is the chance
that you will satisfy a clause ok so the
exponent it's linearly decreasing
function of alpha so it crosses 0 at
some particular point which will call
alpha 1 then it's around 2 to the K log
2 so as soon as you get above this point
alpha 1 the exponent is negative so the
expected number of solutions tends to 0
with and exponentially quickly and the
probability to be to have any solutions
its upper bounded by the expectation so
it means that with high probability you
have no solutions so if if there is a
satisfiability threshold it would have
to occur below the this first moment
threshold alpha 1 okay so it's a it's
it's such a naive calculation so it's
not really surprising that it gives the
wrong answer and alpha 1 is strictly
larger than alpha sat there's a
non-trivial interval between them where
so you're below alpha 1 so the first
moment is large as a function of n but
you're above a facade so there are no
solutions with high probability so
I don't want to harp on this point but
like on the one hand it's not surprising
that such a naive calculation gives the
wrong answer but but it is actually
something a little bit unusual is going
on that you have this random variable
which is most of the time zero and yet
its average value is extremely large so
of course the only way for this to
happen is that on this rare event when
the random variable is nonzero it has to
be extremely large it has to be much
larger than the mean value to compensate
for how rare that event is okay so so
we've seen maybe a hint of some of the
difficulty in locating the threshold and
so so it's to do with this this non
concentration in the number of solutions
and what people have realized is that
this non concentration is is very
closely related to some unusual
properties of the the geometry of the
solution space so again the the solution
space is the subset of the binary cube
and it turns out to have a complicated
geometry and this is related to why
standard approaches do not detect the
threshold so so statistical physicists
made major contributions to this this
problem by by making the realization
that these random csps which come out of
computer science they they can fit into
the framework of this broader class of
models called spin glasses which had
been studied before in the inner physics
literature and for which a lot of
heuristic methods were available and
they they showed how you can take some
of the the heuristic methods and adapt
them to the context of random CSPs and
get some understanding of the the CSP
solution space
so I will talk a bit more about this in
a moment so let me just mention that
something particularly appealing about
the physics picture is that it has
yielded a lot of remarkable conjectures
so conjectures about exact locations of
phase transitions conjectures about the
exact values of the the entropy of the
number of solutions and other things and
in the the context of dense graphs a lot
of a lot of these conjectures have been
rigorously proved so for the matching
problem properties of the SK model and
the Traveling Salesman problem on the
complete graph but I think it would be
fair to say that less is understood
mathematically for for sparse models
where you have bounded average degrees
such as the random k sath model so for
for these sparse models there's a an
extensive physics literature and in
particular some of these papers which
proposed that there is a large class of
these problems that exhibit the same
qualitative behavior and i'll call it
one RSV and try to explain this in a
moment so so these these models are
believed to have this complex phase
diagram so this is the same picture that
has been shown a few times so what it
means is that as you gradually very some
parameters so in our case as you
gradually increase alpha you you see
several distinct behaviors in the
solution space so the structure of the
solution space it undergoes sharp
transitions and some of these have been
have been linked to algorithmic
challenges although this is not
certainly there's a lot of open
questions here
so so specifically the 1rst models there
it's predicted that in the regime of
alpha which just precedes the
satisfiability threshold it's believed
that they have a very specific structure
in the in the type of clustering that
you see and on the the basis of this
structural assumption so if you know how
the how the clusters are distributed and
how they behave on the basis of that
it's possible to make an explicit
conjecture for when the clusters will
stop existing which is the
satisfiability threshold so with the
assumption you can get an explicit
conjecture for what the the threshold
will be and this is what's known as the
the one RSV threshold formula so it's an
explicit formula for the for the
satisfiability threshold and it's it's a
method which can be applied to several
models and the derivation for the model
that we've been talking about was given
in this paper
okay so so in the prior literature the
best upper and lower bounds on the sass
threshold they were by a moment method
for the number of solutions so upper
bounded by by first moment method and
the lower bound is by the the second
moment method or the paley Sigmund
inequality and with increasingly
sophisticated truncation and
conditioning and relating to handle the
the non concentration of this random
variable but what the physics gives us
is that it explains the root cause of
this non concentration and from this
explanation it seems clear that you
cannot further refine the moment method
for the random variable Z to get to get
to the sharp threshold so you can
improve it but you can't detect the
exact threshold by that method and the
the physics picture is it suggests a
better approach to getting a chart
threshold and in particular just as
further support for what I'm saying the
the function alpha star which I put on a
site at the end so it's a pretty
complicated function so it makes it
extremely unlikely that you can get a
rigorous determination of this formula
without without using the the physics
insight that that's leads to this from
this formula
okay so hopefully that's enough
motivation to talk about what replica
symmetry breaking means so so again we
would like to know something about the
the solution space for for a random case
that so you can maybe just take another
perspective that you consider the
uniform probability measure over this
space so you it's a random subset so you
you condition on the the instance of SAT
and then you're looking at this
probability measure over this subset so
so just consider some fixed realization
then you can think about sampling from
this measure so if you sample from this
measure with you what you have is you
have a plus/minus value stochastic
process which is indexed by the the
variables of the graph okay so it's
essentially a rewriting of what we were
asking about before so if you want to
know about the the geometric structure
of the solution space it kind of can be
translated into asking about what
happens if you sample repeatedly from
this measure what is the typical
behavior that you see so but what's the
point of doing this sort of rewriting so
the random measure new it's an example
of a graphical model or factor model or
Gibbs measure Markov random field so
it's an example of this broader class of
models for which a lot of heuristic
methods are available so in particular
models of this type they're classified
as being replica symmetric or replica
symmetry breaking according to the
following criterion so let's assume
everything is plus minus valued so
replica symmetry basically it means that
you have this stochastic process X it's
indexed by the variables of your graph
and replica symmetry says that you have
correlation decays so variables that
far apart with respect to the case at
graph are close to independent so where
does the term replica symmetry come from
what it's saying is that if you take two
iid samples of your your measure news so
the samples are called replicas of the
system and you can consider their
normalized inner product which will call
their overlap so if it's true that
things that are far away are close to
independent then here you have kind of a
sum of a lot of independent thing so you
expect to have some law of large numbers
and you should have concentration so
another characterization of replica
symmetry is that the overlap is
concentrated so by contrast if the
measure has long-range dependencies then
it's called replica symmetry breaking
and in this case the the overlap has a
non-trivial distribution and so maybe
maybe it's obvious at this point but I
should just mention that the reason we
care about this is that if we if we have
correlation decay then of course we have
a lot of probabilistic tools available
to us but if you have a model where
there are long-range dependencies it
becomes much harder to analyze you have
some complicated interaction and it's
it's not clear how to proceed
so then going back to the the geometry
of the solution space the the prediction
is that random case that exhibits both
of these phenomenon indifferent to
regimes of alpha so in this regime here
it's believed that in the solution space
you have a large number of clusters so
exponentially many an N they are all
roughly the same size and so each one is
exponentially small relative to the
total mass so if you're in this regime
and then you you can sample two replicas
so each cluster is very tiny as a
fraction of the whole so if you sample
two independent replicas the chance for
them to land in the same cluster is very
close to zero so with high probability
they land in different clusters and then
the the belief is that different
clusters are far apart and as a result
the two replicas will be sort of
orthogonal to one another and as a
result the they're normalized inner
product will be pretty close to zero so
this is the the replica symmetric regime
that the overlap is concentrated near
zero
but then the the more interesting regime
is closer to the SATA threshold where
the belief is that almost all that the
mass is contained in a bounded number of
clusters which is larger than one so in
this regime the masses sort of
non-trivial II distributed between
different clusters and there are
clusters that take a non-negligible
fraction of the total mass so here if
you sample to ID replicas there are two
things that can happen either they land
in different clusters and then their
overlap will be small or they might land
in the same cluster and then they have a
huge overlap with one another and both
of these two events they they have
non-negligible probability so that means
that the the overlap is not is not
concentrated it has a non-trivial
distribution so this is the the replica
symmetry breaking regime and and again
it you can see it's kind of related to
correlation decay because if you there's
a bounded number of clusters so if you
know the value of a sample at one of the
variables you can say something about
the value far away okay
so maybe just to give a quick argument
about why why do we actually expect to
have clustering in the solution space so
this is just a it's a simple argument
the reason is basically that the graph
is is sparse so so every variable it has
it belongs to a bounded number of
constraints on average and and also each
constraint has some freedom so if you
have a single clause it goes to K
variables and out of the two to the K
ways that you can set the variables only
one of them actually will violate the
clause otherwise that the cause is
satisfied so if you just had one clause
you have a lot of freedom and each
variable has just a bounded number of
clauses that connect to it and so the
consequence is that a typical satisfying
assignment you expect it to have a
positive density which I'll call pie so
some positive density of variables which
are free a meaning that you can freely
change their value without violating any
of the constraints of it they belong to
so like roughly each variable has some
chance to be free so you expect to have
a positive fraction of free variables so
also again the graph is sparse so they
can't all be sitting right next to one
another that so they can't all be
neighbors so you can take out some
smaller subset but still a positive
fraction n times x prime free variables
which don't share any causes among
themselves so are you imposing that as a
constraint that example participating
about
randomly expect there might be a
variable hood clearance sale okay yes
but I just want to extract a positive
density of free variables so let's say
we ignore the variables that participate
in a lot of constraints
so you extract these this some subset of
three variables it can be very small but
but anyway PI prime is positive and
since they don't share any classes among
themselves you can flip any of them
independently any subset of these
variables and you get another satisfying
assignment so the point is that as soon
as you found a single satisfying
assignment it must be with high
probability that it belongs to some
connected component of satisfying
assignments that are all very similar to
it and this component or cluster it must
be exponentially large so at least size
2 to the N times x prime may be much
larger but but anyways it's
exponentially large and this this
discussion it doesn't really use
something very special about the case
that model so all I used is that the
graphics parson that there's some
freedom in the constraints and this is a
pretty generic feature that appears on
other cfps as well as far so so forth so
they are actually a constant of constant
times n number of variables which do not
have any questions on the claws are
connected to them yeah so yes Thanks
yeah I think so that's a good point so
yeah there are some variables that are
isolated but here I want to argue that
even within the the giant component you
have you have a lot of free variables
yeah
okay so maybe I don't know when I was
preparing my slides i got like lost
around this point so so just to remember
we're looking at this problem and then
what we talked about so far is that we
tried to give a tour of how the the
geometry of the solution space is going
to change as you as you gradually
increase alpha and and we said that this
geometry is related to some properties
of correlation decay which are relevant
for the analysis so so maybe this seems
somewhat vague and there there may be
two questions that you might think of
immediately so how did physicists come
up with this picture they have exact
numerical predictions for the locations
of these thresholds so where do the
numbers actually come from and then also
what are the implications of this
picture if you want to rigorously locate
the SATs fresh hold and so for example
like how is it related to the earlier
calculation for the for the first moment
okay so so in order to explain it I will
ask you to take this on faith for a
moment that under some additional set of
assumptions that I'll talk about you get
something like this so you have many
clusters in your solution space and
let's say that we believe that the
number of clusters of size e to the n s
first of all the number of clusters of
some size it's random but first of all
let's believe that the the random number
is concentrated near the the average
number so let's say we believe that and
also both of these are essentially equal
to exponential n times Sigma vests for
some explicit function Sigma which also
depends
on alpha okay so so let's believe this
for a moment and see where it gets us so
so the main point here is that this is a
function that physicists are able to
explicitly calculate and get numbers for
so let's say we believe that then first
of all we know what's the expected value
for Rosie so you should just sum over
all of the the cluster sizes which go
between so s will go between zero and
log to you should sum up the cluster
size e to the n s times the expected
number of clusters of that size so this
is just a rewriting of the first moment
but the point is that you have some
explicit function Sigma so now what you
know is explicitly how the first moment
decomposes into the various cluster
sizes and it's it's dominated by the
point where this function as plus Sigma
of s is maximized so the main
contribution is will come from some
point s star where the derivative is 0
so Sigma prime of s has to be minus 1
and again supposedly we know this
explicit Sigma which also depends on
Alpha so you can just start plotting
curves and see how this maximization
problem changes as you increase alpha
this is just a repeat of a thing ok so
the the picture is that this is for a
fixed value of alpha and then I'm going
to show the curve for several values of
alpha so these are five different values
of alpha so ok so in this regime of
alpha the place where which dominates
the first moment it corresponds to a
positive value of Sigma so the belief
here is that you have so since Sigma is
positive you have exponentially many
clusters they're all roughly of equal
size so as you increase alpha this curve
gradually decreases
and at some point it hits zero and this
is the the dividing line here and then
as soon as it gets below zero so here
the dominant contribution to the first
moment it comes from a negative value of
Sigma which corresponds to a type of
cluster which is exponentially not
likely to occur and then the curve
decreases further and at some point the
the maximum of the curve hits zero and
this is the the satisfiability
transition so above it you are
exponentially unlikely to have any type
of clusters so this is the last curve so
the second curve it's the left boundary
of the middle box and the the fourth
curve is the right boundary of the
middle Kurt middle box and in between
the first moment is dominated by this
cluster size which is very unlikely to
occur what are the cluster sizes that
actually can occur they have to
correspond to positive values of Sigma
so they all correspond to this section
where where Sigma is above the line but
this is the point which is optimal for
the S Plus Sigma of s trade-off so all
of these points are suboptimal and the
most optimal among them is it's this
last one here so so the mean is
dominated by the red point but in a
typical realization of the instance it's
dominated by cluster sizes near the the
purple point and furthermore because
Sigma 0 Sigma 0 it's predicted that the
number of clusters of that size is of
constant order and this is what's called
the condensation phenomenon so so
because all of these are suboptimal the
belief is that the typical value of said
is very small compared with the average
value
and this is from Lanka's target was
called the condensation of the cotton
transition so this is how the replica
symmetry breaking picture relates to
what we talked about before that the the
first moment is is failing to detect the
threshold it's it's because of this this
trade-off here so then back to back to
the assumption so we got this whole
picture and it doesn't really make sense
unless we make this assumption that
expected and typical are the same so so
earlier we wrote this using the
interpretation of Sigma reflects the
expected number of clusters but all of
these picture is here it doesn't make
sense unless Sigma also reflects the
typical number of clusters so we've been
using this assumption and from from this
assumption we got this picture about how
non concentration of this random
variable is related to replica symmetry
breaking and so you might worry that we
built a house of cards because we
assumed concentration to say something
about non concentration so for this all
to make sense you it needs to be that at
the level of this of this equality so at
the level of clusters you don't have
replica symmetry breaking since
otherwise you would expect that you you
don't have this equality so so formally
the the one-step replica symmetry
breaking heuristic what it says is that
at the the bottom level you have
satisfying assignments and they have
this clustering phenomenon and they have
replica symmetry breaking but you go one
step up to the level of clusters and
it's postulates that the the clusters of
assignments they don't exhibit they
don't exhibit a repeat of that
phenomenon so so the cluster is our
replica symmetry
and this assumption it's what underlies
the the explicit derivation of this
function and once you once you have this
explicit function you can read off the
satisfiability threshold so it's the the
last value of alpha for which this
function is anywhere positive
oh so finally with this assumption how
can you get to like actual formulas and
actual numbers so so this is just a
repeat so you can interpret this in in a
few ways one way to understand what this
sentence actually means one way of
saying is that you don't have clusters
within clusters so how would that look
like so the picture would be that this
is a cluster of solutions and somehow
they organized themselves into larger
clusters
so you would have sort of two different
length scales inside the inside the
solution space so one RSV is saying that
this this sort of a picture it doesn't
occur but but earlier what the way that
we defined replica symmetry breaking was
that we talked about the the overlap
between two configurations so what does
it really mean like the overlap between
two clusters and to make it concrete
what we need is some kind of a graphical
model of clusters so if suppose you can
express a cluster as the solution of a
CSP we know what it means for solutions
of a CSP to have some overlap so if we
can have some nice combinatorial
description of what a cluster is then it
can give a clean definition for what it
means for clusters to be replica
symmetry breaking or not so so to get to
some model of clusters you can use the
following ideas so the random graphs are
our local eatery like they have very few
short cycles and trees are great for
formulas because you can have tree
recursions and they give you a fixpoint
equation then you can analyze them the
the whole point is that you can you can
try to approximate random case at on the
case ID on the random graph to a case at
on the tree so what should that mean
obviously the the right answer is not
that you should just define case at on a
tree it can't be the right answer
because a tree is always satisfiable so
in order for the the tree model to have
anything to do with the graph model what
it should mean is that you want to
understand the marginal of this measure
that you started from you want to take a
large neighborhood in the graph so say
the the neighborhood of some variable so
the neighborhood is a tree and then you
want to understand the marginal of
original measure on that large tree
so so by a sort of markov property the
the marginal on the tree it factorize is
like like that so
so the picture that we usually have in
mind is that this is some local
neighborhood you and this is a constant
size and this is the rest of the graph
and this is this part is a tree and here
there are long cycles so so the point is
that the configuration inside the tree
and the configuration outside of the
tree if you condition on what happens at
the boundary of you these things are
conditionally independent so the
boundary separates what's inside from
what's outside so you can rewrite the
the marginal as just the indicator that
all of the causes inside you are
satisfied times the marginal
distribution the joint marginal
distribution of the boundary spins so
what you what you need to understand is
the joint distribution of all these fins
in the graph where u is removed this is
usually called the the cavity graph and
you want to understand the joint law of
these spins
so what's the best that you could hope
for is that they're a product measure so
ideally you would have some measure q1
plus and minus such that this
complicated cavity measure is just the
product of all of iad cues in this ideal
case what can you get so so this should
hold for any you and then let's say that
you take some subset sub graph of you
you want the the marginal on this
smaller sub graph and you can get it in
two ways one way is that you you have
this formula for new sub W and you just
substitute the Q's into here so that's
one way to get it or you can start from
new sub you and take the marginal to get
new sub W so you can get the marginal
the measure new sub W in two different
ways and then if you compare the two it
gives you a fixpoint equation for Q and
Q is just a measure on plus minus so it
can be coded by a single real number so
you can solve this fixpoint equation and
you get some Q star so then once you
have this Q star you know explicitly
what this matter is and then you're
you're basically done so you can if
you're interested in Zed on n variables
you can write it as this telescoping
product all of the these ratios should
be roughly the same so dead end to the
one over N is roughly the same as the
last ratio and this is like the effect
of going from a graph on n minus 1
variables to a graph on n variables so
you just add one more variable and you
need to understand the effect and to
understand the effect all you really
need to understand so you need to know
the interaction between the variable V
that you added and its neighbors which
are in the
the previous graph so there's some
simple interaction between those and
then you need to know the law of its
neighbors which is what you just found
it's the Q star so this is like some
simple explicit formula Phi so if you if
you really have this assumption then it
gives you essentially everything that
you want we just wanted to know if that
is positive but this would give you an
explicit formula for fur said so of
course it's not this simple so why why
would you even expect it to be a product
measure in the first place so in G minus
u so the points at the the boundary of
you they're connected through you so if
you remove you they become far apart in
G minus u so you hope that things that
are far apart are independent so that
means that once replica symmetry
breaking enters then you shouldn't
expect for sorry you shouldn't expect
for such a such a relation to hold you
you should expect them to be dependent
so then what Thanks ok so then what what
saves you is that the one RSP here stick
it says that modification of this
product relation it holds within each
individual cluster so this is related to
the interpretation of one RSV is that
you don't have clusters inside clusters
so you should have a simple picture
inside the clusters and another way of
saying what one RSV is is that you have
a product formula inside individual
clusters so nu sub came' will be the the
restriction of the measure new to a
particular cluster and inside you have a
product measure so then what's the
the subscript here so here why are they
all the same q so you hope that maybe
everybody and the graph looks the same
and then you you just have all the same
q and here there's really no hope of
that because you're inside an individual
cluster so you've lost any hope to have
such a symmetry so you have to have a
vector of queues which are our index by
directed edges but ok so then instead of
the the recursion for a single value of
Q you get a vector of equations so
there's some collection of equations
that these these queues have to satisfy
so so the one RSP correspondence is that
if you want to understand what is a
cluster it's the same as understanding
the measure new restricted to that
cluster and understanding that measure
its equivalent to understand what this
cavity measure is which means that it's
equivalent to understand what the what
the queues are so there's an equivalence
between the the cluster and these BP fix
points why is that a helpful perspective
the BP fixed points their their
solutions of a CSV so the constraints of
the CSP are just the BP equation so you
started from some CSBG and you can lift
it to a new CSP where the solutions are
these queues and they correspond to two
clusters
but now we understand what it means for
four solutions of a CSV to have replica
symmetry breaking you can talk about
their overlap and what one RSV is saying
is that this new CSP where the the
solutions are clusters or BP fixed
points this new CSP is supposed to be a
replica symmetric that that's what one
RSP is saying even if the the original
CSP had replica symmetry breaking so if
it's replica symmetric then this great
condition that we want it before this
where you have this this product measure
we're back in a setting where we do have
such a such a condition and then when
you have this condition you can get a
fixpoint equation for a single queue
which you can solve explicitly for a
single Q star and from that you can read
off the partition function from this
telescoping products argument okay but
we should maybe just unpack what is what
is the capital Q so originally on G the
little Q is a measure on plus minus and
the partition function is just a number
of case at solutions on the lifted
problem the capital Q it's a measure on
the little Q so it's a measure on
measures and the partition function is
the number of Q configurations or the
number of clusters
so with this this transformation what
you can get is some explicit Q star from
which you can read off an explicit
formula for the the number of clusters
which are the solutions of this so once
you can read off this explicit function
it's exactly what we want it before it's
a maximum of this function Sigma and
that can give you the the explicit one
RSV threshold
and I won't go into it but with with
more work along this direction it's
possible to predict the the full curve
sigma bets that I was showing before but
instead let's just focus on the maximum
of the curve which is enough to get the
the SAT threshold so if you're only
interested in the the maximum value of
the curve you can make a further
reduction so here you have a recursion
for four measures on measures which is
maybe a little bit complicated but
actually actually what will happen in
the regime that we're interested in is
that the vast majority of these these
measures on plus minus the vast majority
of them are trivial so they will either
be fully supported on plus or fully
supported on minus and there will only
be a small fraction of these little cues
which are actually non-trivial measures
so the idea of warning propagation is
that let's just forget what exactly the
non-trivial measures are and just
project plus refers to an all plus
measure- refers to an all- measure and
any non degenerate measure let's just
project it to one value called free so
this reduces the the BP configurations
which are vectors of measures to
something much more simple which is just
vectors of plus minus free value this is
just some simple combinatorial objects
and they are in one-to-one
correspondence with the clusters that we
were interested in so these are the
combinatorial objects and they have a
nice interpretation so if you if you
have a variable V which neighbors a
clause a in the bipartite graph the the
interpretation is that the the warning
from a to v it will be plus or minus if
a is forcing me to take value plus or
minus with respect to the cluster that
you're in and the the warning in river
is that V says to the clause a plus or
minus if if the neighbors of V other
than a are telling me to take a
particular value plus or minus so so in
the the rigorous approaches to the
satisfied building threshold so far in
any model where where an explicit
threshold was rigorously located they've
all been going through this
combinatorial interpretation of the
cluster so they don't work with this
they don't work with this model of BP
fix points which are measures but they
work with this plus minus 3 sort of
configurations and so a lot of the the
work uses combinatorial calculations and
kind of informally the the idea what
part of the idea of the proofs is to
show that these are these sorts of plus
minus free configurations they do not
exhibit a clustering phenomenon so
before the whole issue with that the
satisfying assignments they have a lot
of free variables and kind of the the
point here is that if you look at valid
warning propagation configurations
they're they're quite rigid so you
cannot easily change one value to
another without changing a huge number
of values they don't have this sort of
local freedom that we had in the
original model and so they don't really
occur in clusters and this gives sort of
a partial confirmation of the the one
RSP hypothesis and this sort of idea to
appears in the fruit ok so I'm almost
out of time so I'll just mention briefly
some open questions so we've just been
asking if that is is positive or not so
you can ask what is the typical value
and there there are many other aspects
of the phase diagram which are not
rigorously understood especially to do
with the structural properties
in this condensate adre team you can ask
what happens if you go to a positive
temperatures so you lose the the
combinatorial models and but it's
believed that the transitions continue
into a positive temperature and then
finally going back to ondrea's talk
there are models that are believed to
have higher levels of replica symmetry
breaking so you would see such a picture
and the canonical example of that would
be would be max cut and so this would be
an extremely challenging problem and so
this is the formula that I promised
earlier that's it
at the beginning you wrote the expected
value of that what if you try to write
the expected value of logs and does it
is it even something or just a messy
formula that the poor country I mean
that when I say what is the typical
value of said I'm essentially asking
what is the what is the expected value
of log of 1 plus dead for example
so what level of our SB is Mexican bleep
oh it's believed to be a thoughtful
earthy so that you would have an
infinite hierarchy of clusters in Franco
at the the first so there was this paper
as a mercenary and sandwiches it at the
first order max the max cut value is
close to the SK value
okay thank you